[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gérer besoin d'être monsieur bonjour
besoin d'elle
non non ça va merci et c 'est des noix
de pécan j'apporte des noix de pécan à
ma nièce et noix de pécan elle fait des
tartes aux de m'appeler quand même rouge
abl je plains son pauvre mari et c'est
dommage pour les noa story
on vient des plus importants que la
famille ne faites pas comme moi je fais
passer le travail avant la famille
en
je pensais qu'il fallait avant tout être
quelqu'un dans la vie quitte à être une
nullité à la maison
[Musique]
j'ai été un père lamentable
marié lamentable
c'est tout gâcher
[Musique]
je ne méritais aucun pardon
c'est la dernière fois
seul sur devant dieu c'est la dernière
fois
tout ce que je peux dire c'est que je
regrette
[Musique]